الفنان طلال مداح وبكل الصراحه من ينافسك
الان في ساحه الفن
[موسيقى]
الخليجيه لكل قصه حب الفنان خالد
الشيخ
والقاعات
الا يا رجل طلبيه خال الشيخ كان تطلبها
المندوب يحطها ما يوصل الشارع يقولو جيبلي
طلبيه هو يحب البحرين بشكل مو عادي فنان
في البحرين لازم يرتاح لازم يبطل يشتغل
شغل غير
فني خالد اقترح شخصيه جديده
للفنان مالت على
الشعرات
البعض يشوفونه موسيقي والبعض الاخر كان
يشوفه
سياسي نغني لمرحله قادمه ان شاء الله من
الاستقرار باذن الله يدنا على على
سلاح قررت اني انا اطلب من المتعهد
ان يلغيني من جميع الحفلات فقالوا ان خالد
يعني اقبض من البعث لا اكترث او لو مرتب
حتى وصلت الى درجه اني انا
متواطئ صدمه كبيره تبعات الزلزال كنت انا
ارصد تعتقد
ذلك انه غير ولا تغيرنا
احنا من ينافسك الان في ساحه الفن
الخليجيه الوقت الحاضر خالد الشيخ شش علي
يا صاحب من جميع الخلايا افعل الخير تنجو
واتبع اهل
[تصفيق]
الحقا